how big of a threat are cyber attacks
for companies and for individuals like
let's lay out where are we in this world
what's out there it's the Wild Wild West
and it's it's it's
I mean
people want the idea of security but
it's inconvenient so they don't they
push back on it
um and there are a lot of opportunistic
nation-state financially motivated
hackers hackers for the walls you got
three different tiers there
um and and they're they're on the prowl
they have tools they have really good
tools that are being used against us
and I would scale so when you're
thinking of
I don't know what's let's talk about
companies first so say you're you're
talking to um a mid-tier
I wonder what the more most interesting
business is so Google let's let's we can
look at large tech companies and we can
look at
medium-sized tech companies and like you
were sitting in a room with a CTO with a
CEO
and uh the question is how [ __ ] are we
and what should we do what's the low
hanging fruit what's what what are the
different strategies and uh those
companies should consider I mean the
problem is they want a push button they
wanna they wanna out of the box solution
that I'm secure you know they want to
tell people they're secure but and
that's very challenging to have it's
impossible but like if I could if
someone had it they'd be a billionaire
uh you know they'd be Beyond a
billionaire you know because that's what
everybody wants so it's you know you can
buy all the tools you want it's
configuring them the proper way and
there's if anyone's trying to tell you
uh that there's one solution that fits
all their stakehold salesman and there's
a lot of people in cyber security that
are staying oil salesman yeah and I feel
like there's tools if they're not
configured correctly
they uh they just introduce
they don't increase security
significantly and they introduce a lot
of pain for the people they uh decrease
efficiency of the actual work you have
to do so like uh we had um I was at
Google for a Time
and
I think mostly I want to give props to
their security efforts
but user data so like data that belongs
to users is like the holy
like the amount of security they have
around that is incredible so most any
time I had to work with anything even
resembling user days I never got a
chance to work with actual user data
anything resembling that first of all
you have no access to the internet it's
impossible to even come close to the
access to the internet and there's so
much pain to actually like interact with
that data where it I mean it's it was
extremely inefficient in places where I
thought it didn't have to be that
inefficient the security was too much
but I have to give respect to that
because you in that case you want to err
on the side of security but that's
Google yeah but they were doing a good
job of this the reputational harm if it
got out I mean Google you know why is
Google Drive free you know because they
want your data they want you to park
your data there so you know if the re if
they got hacked or leaked information
the reputational harm would be
tremendous but you know for a company
that not it's really hard to do that
right and the company's not as big as
Google or not as tech savvy as Google
might have a lot of trouble with doing
that kind of stuff instead instead of
increasing security they'll just
decrease the efficiency
well yeah so so there's a big difference
between I.T and security and
unfortunately like these mid-side
companies they try to stack security
into their I.T Department your it
department is about business continuity
they're about trying to move business
forward they want your users to get the
data they need to do their job so the
company can grow security is not that
they don't want you to get the data they
you know but there's there's
fine tuning you can do to you know
ensure that I mean as simple as like
having good onboarding procedures for
employees like like you come into my
company you don't need access to
everything maybe you need access to
something for one day turn the access on
don't leave it on I mean I was the
victim of the OPM act the office of
personnel management because old
credentials from a third party vendor
were sitting there and active and the
Chinese government found those
credentials and were able to log in and
steal all my information so a lot could
be helped if you just control the
credentials the access the access
control how long they last and people
who have who need access to a certain
thing only get access to that thing and
not nothing else and then and it just
gets refreshed like that access control
you know like we said setting up people
leaving people leaving the company get
rid of their they don't need control
two-factor authentication you know
that's a big thing you know we is it's I
mean I sound like a broken record
because this isn't anything new this
isn't rocket science the problem is
we're not implementing it and we're not
if we are we're not doing it correctly
uh because these guys are taking taking
us well two-factor authentication is a
good example of something
that I just was annoyed by for the
longest time because yes it's very good
but like it's it seems that it's pretty
easy to implement horribly to where it's
like it's not convenient at all for the
for the legitimate user to use it should
be trivial to to do uh like to
authenticate yourself twice should be
super easy if security if it's slightly
inconvenient for you it's think about
how inconvenient it is for a hacker and
how this is going to move on to the next
person yes yes in theory when
implemented extremely well yeah but I I
just don't think so I think actually if
it's
inconvenient it shows that system hasn't
been thought through a lot do you know
why we need two-factor authentication
people using the same password across
the same site so when one site is
compromised people just take that
username and password it's called
credential stuffing and just stuff it
across the internet so if 10 years ago
when we told everybody don't use the
same [ __ ] password across the
internet across the funnel sites maybe
two-factor wouldn't be needed yeah so
you would need to factor if everyone did
a good job with passwords yeah
right but I'm saying like the two Factor
authentication it should uh it should be
super easy to authenticate myself uh in
some with some other device really
quickly like there should be it should
be frictionless like you just hit okay
okay and anything that belongs to me
yeah and like I should it should very
importantly be easy to set up what
belongs to me uh I don't know the full
complexity of the cyber attacks these
platforms are under they're probably
under insane amount of attacks yeah
you've got it right there that people
have no idea these large companies how
often they're attacked you know on a per
second basis and they have to fight all
that often and pick out the good traffic
in there so yeah I would there's no way
I'd want to run a large tech company